[تصفيق]
على المنصه يقف مسيطرا يهزا من باقي
المرشحين ولا يهتموا لاي كياسه او
بروتوكولات فالهدف امام عينيه واضح وهو
كشف المستور وتدمير الخصم
هذا هو الرئيس الخامس والاربعون الذي يطمح
ليعتلي كرسي الرئاسه في الانتخابات
القادمه
بدا يعد العده لمهاجمه اكثر المرشحين
الجمهوريين جديه في تشكيل خطر عليه حاكم
ولايه فلوريدا رند سانتوس
هو اخطر منافس لقد اتخذ الكثير من سياسات
ترامب ووضعها موضع التنفيذ وهو حقا يستميل
الى الاشخاص الذين قد يدعمون دونالد ترامب
بطريقه او باخرى لذلك في هذا الصدد ديسانس
هو التحدي الاكبر
تعتمد على ثلاثه عناصر الاولى اظهار بانه
يفتقد الى الولاء الثانيه تخبطه في
التعامل مع ملف كورونا والثالثه ضعفه في
ملفات السياسه الخارجيه
اعتقد ان دول ترامب سيفعل كلما في وسعه
لجعل رون يبدو وكانه المرشح الخطا للح
الجمهوري والسبب في ذلك ان دول ترامب
بصفته رئيس الحزب الجمهوري خسر الانتخابات
الثلاثه الاخيره لم يحصد الحزب نتائج جيده
خسر الحزب الجمهوري الاكثريه في مجلس
الشيوخ في عام 2022 وخسر الحزب ايضا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في عام 2020 لذلك
يعتقد الكثير من الناخبين ان الوقت قد حان
للتغيير
يرى ان دي سانتوس من صناعته فقد كان مرشحا
مغمورا الى ان قامت بدعمه ماليا وسياسيا
الى جانب ارتباكه في التعامل مع فيروس
كورونا من اغلاق للمدارس والمحلات
التجاريه الى فتح عام ادى الى نسب اصابات
قياسيه موضوع حرب اوكرانيا اظهر ضعف حاكم
فلوريدا من وجهه نظر ترامب فهو لا يقر
بالانفاق العسكري لاوكرانيا ولا بجديه
بوتين في تحدي حلف شمال الاطلسي
استراتيجيه ترامب تعتمد على تدمير الخصم
الجدي لذا فهو لم يتطرق الى نيه مايك بنس
بالترشح او وزير خارجيه السابق مايك فهو
يحتفظ بهذا الخيار الى مرحله قادمه نادر
البلبيسي العربيه